in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Chris
is with us hi Chris how are you doing
well finally dry after all the rain and
everything so it was great where you
from I'm from Lincolnton Georgia it's a
small town in between Augusta and Athens
okay Georgia Bulldog country absolutely
the deep in Bulldog country oh yeah I
love it fun well welcome to Nashville
and you're here to do your debt-free
scream I most certainly am how much of
you paid off sir right right at sixteen
thousand five hundred dollars very cool
good for you and how long did that take
you
it took right at sixteen months four
hundred and seventy three days the exact
okay it worked
sure income during that time range I
started off at about twenty four
thousand dollars a year and now make
about twenty seven four and I also
started a side business um during that
time making furniture out of recycled
items and stuff like that and I made a
little over three thousand dollars to
put towards the dead
oh good doing that as well so very cool
very cool you're single I am cool how
old are you I am just turned twenty four
way to go so what kind of debt was a
16-5 oh it was about four thousand
dollars on a motorcycle and the rest was
student loans okay did you sell stuff I
did kind of not anything really big just
you know kind of a I sold a bunch of
stuff on eBay anything I could find that
you know wasn't stuck to my bedroom or
anything just got rid of it you know
dude you really paid off a lot of debt
with your income in a short amount of
time and I did live with my brother um
when I did that it wasn't free buddy was
cheaper than than any other option
outros oh okay it's going nice to have
family help out oh yeah he's a big fan
of yours too and so he's got to be proud
of you then oh yeah very cool so what
happened 16 months ago I mean you're
what 22 years old at that point I was
and and you're sitting there with all
this debt and what woke you up what
happened well I am I remember it was it
was in January 2015 and I just woke up
one morning at like 3 o'clock in the
morning and I just couldn't sleep you
know I don't know why I was bothering me
all of a sudden but um you know I just
woke up and I was thinking you know and
I just gotten a raise at work also a
couple dollars an hour and that's when I
said okay when I get when I make more
money I'll do it you know people
always making excuses you got to make
more money you got to do whatever and I
made more money then and I just spent
more money they've made no extra
progress or anything and until I said
you know what I'm doing and I'm just
gonna buckle down and fix it and I mean
it was to the point to where for the
first couple of months I got off social
media I did everything I could to just
create new habits mm-hm and just be
doing you know I'm completely changed
and from that day forward and then 473
days later I made it Wow
so how did you know what to do well um I
my you know I said my brother was a big
fan of yours and I would come home and
he would be watching your video channel
and there would be this this guy telling
people that they're doing dumb things
and they need to be smarter and and
everything and and I guess that would've
been in like late 2014 and then I was
like okay well I want to get out of debt
and I'm tired of living paycheck to
paycheck I don't have you know I didn't
have money for emergencies or anything I
was like well I'm gonna fix it you know
and and he told me about the Total Money
Makeover I read that and I read the
whole thing in like a day and just I
mean cuz you can do that if you're not
on social media and stuff you can run
you know make some you got some free
time and I just went after it just from
day one and I remember I think you know
to stay motivated I remember somebody
that actually did a debt free scream
here I guess a few months ago say that
you had to redefine what progress looks
like and it's tough for me I mean
obviously as young as I am I'm a very
impatient person you know I don't want
to send one payment off a month or
everything I don't and I had to do
something to say motivate and I think
when I was doing the side business you
know I would leave work and then I would
just go home and work some more and I
always felt like I was you know every
single day moving a step forward you
know whether it be spending a little bit
less at the grocery store trying to use
a little less fuel one week or
everything you do use have to see it as
progress and and know that it's it's
helping you move in the right direction
absolutely very cool
I mean you paid a thousand bucks a month
off making twenty four to twenty seven
thousand dollars a year that's
impressive it was it was tough it was
beans and rice not exactly we were
actually talking to a lady I made means
and rice one time and it was horrible I
can't I didn't realize I didn't realize
you're supposed to like soak them
overnight season my stuff I had no clue
and I called my mom I'm making beans and
rice and she was like did you soak them
nice sounds like something I would do
so from now on it's it's just Minute
Rice uncle Bria yeah yeah I love it
that's fun way to go dude I'm very proud
of you how does it feel now oh it's
great you know and I really honestly I
really haven't changed my lifestyle a
whole lot since I paid it off you know
I'm working on the 3a and 3b mm-hmm
moving towards that but it's nice every
you know I feel like I'm moving forward
every single week I go put money in my
savings accountant you know I I do all
that stuff and it's nice to see it grow
and I feel like every time you want to
wake up to go to work you know I'm I'm
going to work to build a future and not
pay for the past mmm
you know that's a good line and yeah I
thought about that was like I'm gonna
say something smart when I come up here
that there's your oh yeah that one's
free that's free there's no charge no
charge well I won't ask for another then
oh my gosh good for you man
way to go you know what's impressive is
is that you have completely changed
haven't you
oh yeah I mean you're bleeding you're a
different guy you know and I mean really
I was the kind of guy okay I get my
paycheck on Friday and I'm gonna blow
most of it on the weekend you know and I
go now and you know I use my budget and
I put money in envelopes and I mean yeah
you know I do fun stuff still but sure
you know it's you know there are limits
to that you know wonderful very careful
for sure very cool I'm very proud of you
thank you very well done
I appreciate sharp young guy sharp young
guy so what's your advice to a 20 to 24
year old out there listening single guy
not making a ton of money making 24 27
what's your advice to them on how to get
out of debt I think you know you just
have to start doing it you know it's and
you have to realize you you can't expect
the fort to work overnight because it's
not you just have to say you know every
day I'm gonna move forward I'm gonna do
something to better this situation you
know whether it be you know doing some
extra work somewhere just making any
extra money you can or you know cut the
cable off or you know whatever you can
think of just to make progress and but
it worked you know for me it worked and
but I mean it was every single day after
it was I mean yeah I feel like you could
ask my friends no to you it dominated my
life for quite a while you know
but it's worth it I would much rather
have done it when I'm 22 or 23 or
whatever instead of you know 40 with a
massive mortgage and I you know huge
pile of credit card debt and [ __ ] and
absolutely you know kids to worry about
and all that stuff and I figured you
know it'd be the best time of my life to
clean up the rest only good for you well
yeah we're gonna go back in debt no no
never too hard to get out yeah it's uh
it's worth it for sure area all right
well done sir your hero product we're
gonna give you a copy of Chris Hogan's
new book retire inspired which is all
about building wealth and number one
bestseller and it's all about where
you're headed yeah actually met him out
of one of his live events oh what's new
very cool we'll give you a signed copy
nice guy get you set up
he is a nice guy thanks me for that
voice yeah Chris and all Chris from
Augusta Georgia 16,500 paid off in 16
months count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one
that's how you do a dead free screen ah
well done sir
very well done life is good hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show and so
you have to break the cycle you have to
flip this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind